il fait actuellement 34 degrés mapou
risque de soins teitel une limace bon
j'avoue faire les courses c'est vraiment
un thème bien gentil et bien banal on
dirait un peu oui qui fait un podcast
j'sais pas si vous avez remarqué mais
quand tu fais les courses au pays des
jouets mais en même temps faire les
courses c'est bien en parler parce que
c'est vraiment un truc de la vie
quotidienne qu'on fait tous et surtout
un moment de convivialité
[Musique]
alors évidemment dans un magasin ya
plein de marques 1 cet avis alors si
vous voyez une marque dans cette vidéo
c'est pas un placement de produit c'est
plutôt 50 mille placement de produit
gratuit
je sais pas vous mais moi quand je fais
les courses c'est toujours la même
routine à chaque fois je suis une petite
liste de courses bien propre que
j'oublie je prends toujours le paquet au
fond de la pile
histoire de gagner deux jours de
péremption il ya toujours ce mec planté
pile poil devant là où tu veux prendre
un produit
j'ai toujours envie de mettre le truc du
caddie dans la fente comme si les
inventeurs il y avait jamais pensé je
vois toujours quelqu'un que je connais
et je fais semblant de ne pas le
connaître
et enfin je prends toujours là que la
plus rapide qui devient la moins rapide
alors je sais pas non plus comment vous
comporter au magasin mais moi je pense
que je suis pas toujours le client idéal
quand je fais tomber un produit et qui a
pas de témoins bah je ramasse pas j'aime
bien reposé les produits au mauvais
endroit
j'essaye toujours de passer à la caisse
- des articles avec 11
parfois je mange le produit avant de
l'avoir payé et je suis en stress comme
si j'ai braqué une blague
et puis elle a pesé pour payer moins
cher j'ai toujours envie de mettre
l'étiquette d'un autre produit vous êtes
sûr que c'est des bananes ça oui c'est
des manades ronde de la réunion bon à
part ça je vous rassure je suis un
client honnête mais quand je sors du
magasin sans avoir à acheter
je repère que le mec de la sécu crois
que j'ai volé un truc sinon j'ai rien
acheter jeu quand il ya une dégustation
je sais pas si parce que c'est gratuit
et j'ai toujours l'impression que c'est
le meilleur fromage au monde je peux me
permettre
na li zhi on dirait qu'il vous plaît il
est à 15 euros
j'aime pas trop fait à chaque fois à la
caisse
j'suis pas si vous faites pareil moi je
regarde les gens et en fonction des
produits qu'ils achètent
j'imagine leur vie d'accord donc elle
dans la vie sa passion c'est le pâté
puis ce soir mon avis là un petit
d'haïti et il compte bien conclure elle
elle doit être en bout pleine rupture
amoureuse
georges e manche du ice cream devant
bridget jones ah ouais alors lui
manquait juste un truc pour aller aux
toilettes
à mon avis un peu plus là en parlant de
pq dans le corps trouvé ça ridicule à
témoin même à 30 ans j'assume toujours
pas d'acheter du pq en fait j'ai peur de
me faire interpeller par quelqu'un
[ __ ] norman fait des vidéos mais
qu'est ce que tu fous là bas là je fais
du hockey sur glace là je fais du rock
et sur quoi non je déconne c'est qu'on
me prend une petite photo sebastian
veron ce sac à la caisse quand est
produit sur le tapis et qui te rends
compte que tu as oublié un truc soit tu
laisses tomber ce trop tard ou soit tu
pars
en mission impossible merde j'ai oublié
les yeux doux bien un truc je reviens
j'arrive tout le rayon bordel si feu
[Musique]
voyez toujours pas revenue et en suivant
bonjour aux fêtes faut dire aux
caissiers aux caissières que remplir les
sacs et payer c'est vraiment deux
actions qu'on peut pas faire en même
temps la pression est toujours totale
[Musique]
impossible déjà tu galères et en plus tu
as un public toute la file te regarde
vénère sérieux [ __ ] c'est pour ouvrir
un sac quelqu'un la salive alors des
fois au supermarché il propose des
caisses automatiques mondiale te parle
comme un maternelle avec le son bien
fort tout le monde content que tu
galères posez votre article sur la
plateforme n'ont pas à cet article la tu
es con ou quoi
veuillez passer votre article devant le
scanner c'est simple pourtant regard de
tout le monde autour de toi y arrive
un assistant va venir vous aider et vu
comment à chaque fois c'est un échec je
me dis la caisse automatique
elle porte bien son nom à chaque fois
que tu utilises automatiquement tu as
besoin d'une vraie caissière
la solution c'est peut-être de faire ses
courses en ligne au moins j'ai déjà
essayé ces pratiques 1 mais ça a ses
limites
ah non il n'y a plus rien à manger
t'inquiète je m'occupe de tout je
commande en ligne
voilà on mange mercredi entre 17 heures
et 19 heures merci d'avoir regardé cette
vidéo j'espère que maintenant quand vous
irez faire vos courses et ben vous
sentirez moins seul et puis il faut
relativiser
1 la préhistoire nos ancêtres il partait
faire les courses avec des lances et
c'était pas sûr de revenir vivant
maintenant tu peux acheter des produits
des quatre coins du monde en 2 secondes
à côté de chez toi
on n'a plus franchement les mêmes
problèmes ça me saoule je pète un câble
faut pas me parler j'ai pas trouvé le
rayon sans gluten comment je vais mourir
tu m'expliques telle réponse tu
m'envoies sur what's app
si vous avez aimé n'oubliez pas de
mettre un petit femme de table et en
chine grâce à la nouvelle mise à jour
youtube quand vous cliquez ici là sur ce
bouton depuis un téléphone ou un ordi
pas ça fait un truc nouveau alesi a
essayé cliquer avec votre doigt votre
souris pour wall a pas mal non plutôt
cool hyper simple pour s'abonner
beaucoup plus instinctif donc merci
monsieur youtube et puis merci à vous je
vous aime énormément lâché un petit
poussin adp au revoir